مسلسل الاخبار اهلا بكم اعرب الرئيس
الامريكي اجتماعي قمه مع نظيره الفرنسي
اذا
ظهر رغبه في انهاء الحرب على اوكرانيا
في اوكرانيا امر غير ولد
او تدين جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها روسيا
في اوكرانيا
قال وزير الخارجيه الرئيس واشنطن حولت
اوكرانيا الى خطر وجودي على روسيا وصف
منظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا بالكيان
الهامشي واتمنيت بالسعي لفرض هيملته على
العالم
قال الامين العام لحلف الناتو ان الحلفه
سيدافع عن كل حلفاء خاصه في الجانب الشرقي
كذا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الحاجه الى صياغه نظام الامنيه
جديده في القاره الاوروبيه
دبلوماسيون انها حكومات الاتحاد الاوروبي
اتفقت على تطبيق حد اقصى لسعر نفط الروسي
المنقول بحرا وكشفت رؤيه اذا طلعت على
وثيقه تظهر ان الاتفاق ينص على ادراج اليه
لابقاء سعر النفط الروسي ادنى من مستوى
السوق بنسبه 5% كما نقلت روتز عن مسؤول
بمجموعه السبعه ندول المجموعه تقترب جدا
من الاتفاق على حد الاقصى لسعر النفط
الروسيه
دولارا للبرميل مضيفا انه ينبغي الانتهاء
من الاتفاق الاثنين المقبل على اقصى تقدير
قال مجلس الامن القومي التركي انه سيتخذ
خطوات لازمه لمراعي اي نشاط لما وصفها
بتنظيم الارهابي في شمال سوريا
بان الجيش التركي قصف مواقع لما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه في محيط مدينه منبج
بريف حلب ومواقع اخرى في رفيقي الحسكه
والرقى الشماليه سوريا
قال المتحدث باسم البنت
القويه
لشمال سوريا
شمالي سوري
طلب مظلوم عبد القائد العام لما تعرفوا
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه روسيا بتحمل
مسؤولياتها كونها دوله ضامنه لاتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار في تركيا
ومع تركيا عفوا وباعلاني مواصفاته بمواقف
اكثر حزما
افادت هي البث الاسرائيليه بين المنظومه
الدفاعيه لساليه وضعت في حاله استنفار حول
غزه تحسبا لعمليه انتقاميه من حركه الجهاد
اسلاميه وكان قياديان في حركه الجهاد قد
استشهد خلال اقتحام قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه ومخيمه جنيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]